and now I am very happy to be able to
bring on the eighth most listened to
radio talk show host in the United
States I'm sure is a favorite of many of
you if not most and if he isn't if
you're not familiar with him tune in on
Salem Radio Network to the Mike
Gallagher show Mike Gallagher one of the
foremost political commentators in the
United States is here with us today
please give him a big
welcome so this is what America looks
like
huh look around because the media might
tell a different story about this
Gathering look around the mainstream
media might say oh a hundred or two
hundred people showed up you know those
crazy tea parters well look around and
look all the way down this street this
is the face of the United States of
America as a talk radio host and a Fox
News Channel contributor and I'm proud
of my association with Fox
News it gives me great joy to represent
Grassroots Americans this is the kind of
Grassroots effort that will beat back
this
mosque and speaking of Grassroots
Americans how about the woman the
driving force behind today the lady from
Atlas schr drugs the Blogger the author
hamila Geller and the job she has done
today she's the kind of Grassroots voice
that gets things done she's the reason
that this kind of an event will make a
difference and she's the reason that so
many of us can be proud on this solemn
commemorative day a sunny bright
Manhattan September day like 911
2001 many of the families as you've
heard today whose loved ones lost their
lives at the hands of Muslim extremists
are positively anguished over the idea
of a mosque being built so close to the
spot where their precious family member
took their last breath today as we
memorialize those who died and remember
the family friends and countrymen left
behind we stand in solidarity with those
who believe that an Islamic cultural
center and mosque in the shadows of
where where the Twin Towers once proudly
stood is an appalling lack of
sensitivity and respect in fact it is
the height of disrespect
respect and a blatant and offensive
assault on the legacy of those who were
slaughtered by extremists who did what
they did in the name of Allah this week
President Obama suggested that this 911
this year should be used as a date to
try and develop a better understanding
of the Muslim
World while many of us while many of us
would deeply agree that perhaps it is
time to try and better understand a
world that could produce so many
Fanatics who believe the terror and
bloodshed and the killing of innocent
men women and children in any way is
acceptable the president is definitely
not on the same page with most Americans
and New Yorkers over this
mosque his lack of compassion for 911
victims like the ones we've heard from
today is breathtaking shame on you
President
Obama ladies and gentlemen may me may we
one day have an American president who
has the courage and wisdom to suggest
that perhaps the anniversary date of
9/11 could be used as a day for the
Muslim world to try and understand the
non-muslim
world as a big mouth on the radio a
white Methodist American citizen may I
be so bold as to speak for a moment for
this non-muslim world I think I can
safely represent This World by reminding
all that this debate has never been
about religious liberty no one has ever
suggested that mosques be banned no one
has ever advocated any serious effort
for a Muslim moratorium no one has never
ever suggested that Muslims aren't free
to Worship in the way they wish to
Worship in fact most of us understand
that this Ground Zero mosque is likely
on solid legal footing no this is not a
legal or technical debate nor is it any
kind of anti-muslim Hysteria this is
simply a belief that family members
whose loved ones were brutally murdered
the ones we heard from today should be
respected when they say that an Islamic
mosque at this site is wildly
inappropriate of
course of course most of the mosque
supporters already know all of this many
on the other side don't think this is an
assault on religious Liberties for
Muslims they simp like the confrontation
they Revel in the controversy and the
heartache and the pain and The Angst
that they have created well the solution
is simple it's easy if the developers
truly want to Foster Goodwill and
understanding they will do the right
thing and move the mosque somewhere
else one gesture one single gesture of
good faith on their part by respecting
the family members wishes would do so
much more good than one single building
at one particular location could ever
hope to
accomplish and while we remember the
days when we had a president who would
stand up to Islamic terrorists maybe
what may we once again have a mayor a
New York mayor who has the courage and
the wisdom to stand with the majority of
Americans over an issue like this one
sadly we don't have that now
we have there was a
mayor there was a mayor who was such a
man he was the mayor on 9/11
2001 that's a mayor we can believe
in and so ladies and gentlemen on this
holy and emotional day this passionate
day this angry day where we have a right
to let our voices be heard May our
prayers in our hearts be with two themes
one that the organizers and developers
of this mosque will do the right thing
and two may God's loving hand comfort
each and every one of you who had the
courage to be here today May his hand
Comfort The Grieving and the sad and all
of us today and all days God bless all
of you God bless those who have lost so
much God bless New York City and God
bless America